I want to start with something a little different
today.
You know, we pointed out that both during
the Trump administration and even after his
election loss, during which he became the
lame duck president that he is now, as there
were many public scandals and much media coverage
of some aspects of what Donald Trump was doing,
there continued to be Republicans doing things,
horrible things, including, of course, Mitch
McConnell helping to confirm extremist judges,
but also rolling back environmental regulations
which allow more pollution and all sorts of
stuff.
The point was, while this public facing scandal
ridden fiasco continued below the surface,
the Republicans were doing things that are
really horrible.
Well, we have now gotten a list of the things
that Donald Trump is going to try to get done,
hopefully without much attention being paid
to them in the remaining seven weeks of his
presidency.
And they are mostly outrageous.
And they include, listen to this, reinstating
the death penalty via both firing squad and
the electric chair before Donald Trump leaves
office.
And on the one hand, you have much of the
developed world which has rightly moved away
from the death penalty altogether.
And we've talked about the death penalty extensively
before.
Whether you believe the death penalty should
be eliminated because it is fiscally not conservative,
it costs more actually in the United States
than keeping somebody in prison for the rest
of their lives.
And we've talked about why, whether it's because
you believe in small government and that the
government should not be killing people, whether
it's because you believe in the unfair way
that the death penalty is disproportionately
applied in certain cases and not in others
anyway.
We've had we've adjudicated the death penalty
so many times and many developed countries
have figured that out and have moved away
from the death penalty altogether.
The United States.
Meanwhile, while some states have moved away
from the death penalty, Donald Trump wants
federally to rush in the reinstatement of
electric chair and death by firing squad executions
for the death penalty.
There are a whole bunch of other proposals
as well, which we are going to talk about
now.
Why?
Why would Trump be trying to add new ways
that the government can kill people via the
death penalty?
Why would they do this?
One of the things that has slowed down executions
over the last decade or more in the United
States is that there are some there is sometimes
scant availability of lethal injection drugs.
So the idea is, well, let's move ahead with
some of these executions by adding firing
squad and electric chair as options for how
the federal government would carry out these
executions.
Now, before we move forward, I think it's
important to remind you that most executions,
most that death, most death penalty executions
in the United States are done by states.
Federal executions are relatively rare.
And so this would only change the federal
rules.
And to give you an idea of how lopsided the
numbers are since 1977.
There have been fewer than 50 federal executions
since 1977, OK, but there have been around
1500 execution by states.
So it's extraordinarily lopsided.
If Trump does this, it would only affect federal
executions.
But the point is it would start increasing
that number more quickly.
I'm against the death penalty period and I
don't care how you're doing it.
I am opposed to it.
If you're interested in that topic, it hasn't
come up on the show for probably at least
a year.
You can find some of my archived clips on
the YouTube channel.
Now, other changes Donald Trump is trying
to rush through in the waning days of his
presidency.
He wants a change at the USDA to allow faster
chicken processing lines in slaughterhouses.
I don't know if you've seen what a chicken
processing line looks like.
I think it's an interesting thing to to to
understand.
As you all know, I'm not vegan or vegetarian,
but I do think it's important to understand
what these mass processing facilities look
like.
And it chicken processing is done essentially
on an assembly line.
And the idea is to allow the assembly line
to move more quickly.
And the reasons not to do that would be it
would increase the chance of errors, contamination,
possible errant cuts, which could spread bacteria
as well as risk to workers.
But Donald Trump wants to allow that.
Donald Trump wants to make some additional
rule changes that would make it more difficult
for Joe Biden to quickly undo some of the
environmental restrictions that Donald Trump
eliminated.
And Trump also trying to push through a regulation
that would exclude transgender.
Individuals from federally funded homeless
shelters, which is just vile, disgusting and
unnecessarily cruel, Trump would also loosen
water-saving standards on showerheads.
Now, that actually came up at a bunch of Trump
rallies, which we covered leading up to the
election, where Trump would be shown that
if Joe Biden were to win, you'd have trouble
flushing toilets, you'd have trouble getting
good water pressure in the shower.
Trump at one point even wildly claimed that
if Joe Biden were to win, heating and cooling,
indoor heating and cooling might be eliminated.
You might have none of it under Joe Biden,
which was a completely deranged claim to begin
with.
And just to get ready, I have stopped using
heat.
I want to be ready for when Biden takes over,
but I'm hoping that that one doesn't come
to pass.
That's a joke.
By the way.
Imagine what kind of a person you have to
be to say, OK, I've got seven weeks, my last
and final seven weeks to impact this country.
What can I do in this time?
And the idea that comes to you as let me expand
the ways in which the federal government is
allowed to kill people.
That's a good use of my time.
When you hear Trump wants to bring back firing
squads, it almost sounds like a headline from
The Onion, a satirical news headline.
Then you read the article and it is all too
real.
Trump ignored the pandemic since day one,
but capital punishment and shower heads are
at the top of his important item list to get
done before leaving office.
I would understand if the world takes a while
to forgive us
for
this presidency.